lobby of Ramsey solutions Adam and Kara
are with us hey guys how are you I said
we're great we're doing great welcome
welcome good to have you where do you
guys live outside of Peoria Illinois oh
fun not too bad a drive did you drive or
fly we drove okay cool welcome to
Nashville so you're here to do a
debt-free screen we sure are how much
have you paid off we've paid off about
thirteen thousand dollars excellent and
how long did that take you took us about
18 months okay making what kind of money
around 40,000 good for you way to go
what kind of debt was the 13,000 oh it
was mostly student loans in a vehicle we
did a little medical and some doctorate
work for him as well in there so sure
you were kind of normal yeah got a
little bit of every kind of dad I'm sure
just like on a normal American family
broke that's right what happened 18
months ago that made you decide to get
on this journey tell me the story well
I'm a pastor of a church and we were
looking to do an outreach in our
community to just help people better
understand how to manage the money and
how to do it in a godly way and so we'd
heard about this financial peace
university thing and so we said well
let's look into offering it but before
we do that we need to go through it
ourselves to see what it's like and okay
so we took a summer and just went
through it together with another couple
at our church and it really started to
change our lives and so we were blessed
very much through it Wow very cool well
good for you for checking us out for you
put the whole church in it I appreciate
you doing that that's good and now you
got a testimony to go with it huh
absolutely that's very cool because when
you lead that way you're really leading
that's good stuff way to go you guys so
you kind of went in so okay I check this
out to make sure it's okay for the
church and turns out hits you between
the eyes so what was the biggest shocker
when you were in the class that you kind
of didn't see coming oh it was what do
you think oh I would say probably when
we put together our first budget oh and
you know we had always been cheap or
frugal as i like to say and i don't know
just like we need to spend less we need
to make this go further but i don't
think we'd ever really sat down and
given every dollar
so working through that I think was a
bit of an eye-opener when we said ho
this is where the money's trickling out
of our monthly income and so I think
that was probably the biggest shock but
also one of the funnest parts about it
as well to see where that money was
going in to get a better handle you feel
kind of powerful when you get it done
yeah it's you're like ding ding I can do
this yeah now tell the truth pastor
God's watching did y'all have a big
fight on that first budget night no not
us sarcastically the other people did no
we're the passenger his wife yeah we had
a good very good discussion of spenders
and save us elphias guy you would have
always said that I'm the free spirit
yeah I am but um it turns out i'm much
more nerdy than he anticipated as well
oh I'm the one running the spreadsheet
every month good night you do the detail
ideal but you're also the spender that's
I am as well that mean that's me I'm the
detail guy but I'm the natural spender
strands the natural saver and down to
the details it's unusual for it to have
a nerd that is a free spirit but they
are there I am one definitely I'm one of
those weird animals myself so very cool
congratulations so uh what did it change
about you guys that you didn't know what
it was going to change hmm oh man that
was it were there any kind of like
revelations as you went alone um that
this is gonna sound terrible it's not as
hard as we thought it was going that's
good so um once once we did get that
budget down or you know that sort of
thing it just all sort of fell into
place as long as we stuck to it so I
mean there were a few bumps along the
way but as long as we stuck in there and
hung in then it was it worked and it
just did I kinda have a feeling y'all
had a pretty great marriage to start
with so oh it just had to increase the
communication sir hmm sir okay all right
very cool good good for you guys way to
go cool so I pastor you went into this
thinking that is kind of practical
outreach for the community and you're
thinking this is a good way for to teach
people about money God's ways of doing
it
were there any spiritual insights that
you didn't see coming did you get have a
spiritual aha moment oh I think it just
goes back to what you said about you
know in helping our marriage and helping
us connect better there as husband and
wife and connecting in that way because
that's just something that had always
been a little bit of attention what with
one of us being a spender and one of us
being a saver but to be able to come
together and have those conversations
and work through those things together
was a great blessing not just for us
financially but for marriage as well and
in fact whenever we talk to younger
people we always say you know oh if we
would have had this when we were first
married I would have helped us those
first few years and you know if you
would look into this and just be willing
to give it a chance it'll help you too
yeah very cool very cool what's the name
of your church grace bible church very
good good and what are your kiddos names
and ages this is Maxine he's seven and
this is penny and she's five awesome
very cool have they been practicing
their debt free oh yes we had to tone it
down in the car no you don't oh yeah
yeah we're allowed to yell at the top of
your lungs it's a new form of praise and
worship you guys love it alright Adam
and Cara max and Penny Peoria Illinois
thirteen thousand dollars paid off in 18
months making 40,000 a year count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one we're debt-free
love it love it love it way to go you
guys absolutely a great job
you